it's not just in your head when it comes
to how we all experience life bad is
generally stronger than good
we remember trauma more than we remember
joy we're brought down by criticism more
than were elevated by praise and we pay
more attention to bad news than good a
new book called the power of bad by
journalist John Tierney and psychologist
Roy F Baumeister explores the negativity
effect or the universal tendency for
negative events and emotions to affect
us more strongly than positive ones the
negativity effect shapes everything we
do from our personal relationships to
how we do our careers to how we vote to
what media we consume but the power of
bad isn't just one more cause for
despair the book subtitle is how the
negativity effect rules us and how we
can rule it and it offers practical tips
on all sorts of ways to approach life so
that we can be happy productive and
well-adjusted I sat down with John
Tierney a contributing editor at the
Manhattan Institute city journal and a
former New York Times columnist and
reporter to talk about the root causes
of the negativity effect and how to
combat it
john tierney thanks for talking reason
Thanks
so explain the negativity effect what
what is it it's the universal tendency
for for bad events bad emotions to
affect us more strongly than good ones
it's also called negativity bias it's
basically this tendency that the bad
parenting makes a big difference good
parenting doesn't criticism hurts so
much more than praise does there's much
more brain activity when you see
something negative than when you see
something positive can you give give
some concrete examples of this you know
we're we're bad clearly overpowers good
well a bad first impression is really
tough to shake whereas a good first
impression can be overcome you know you
can always screw it up later right
exactly and you know penalties work a
lot better than rewards as far as
motivating people and we have a chapter
in the book about how looking at the
history of religions that religions that
preach hell grow much faster than ones
that basically promise you eternal
rewards people you know that's what
feels abused people were mean the brain
just evolved to respond to bad thing you
talked about at various points a four to
one ratio of 5 to 1 ratio of where you
know you you know it's like four bad
things but you need a rather one bad
thing you need for fought good things to
overcome it what are some cases where
that's the case well they found a prince
of study people's Diaries when they kind
of and when they count up or workers
Diaries and they kind of the good things
that happened and the bad things and
then people's overall mood after that
and they find that it takes about four
good things to make up for one setback
award you know one bad moment at work
takes four good things to overcome that
basically people who were happy tend to
have three or four times more good
emotions and bad emotions are more good
days than bad days
you know right it's kind of stumbled
into this early on where he was in this
relationship and he wasn't sure whether
to stay or not because they were you
know he's happy most of the time but
there were some really bad days and he
just started counting is today a good
day or a bad day and he found that it
was two to one and he just felt this
isn't really enough yeah and did you
guys even talk about how in the sex is
not you know sex can help but SEC good
sex isn't gonna save a relationship
right I mean bad sex matters a lot more
than you know than good sex but I mean
that's another example of the four to
one rule they you know in fact you know
psychologists talk about the or
therapists talking about the four [ __ ]
for every fight rule basically that not
by their I'm glad to hear it exists but
it's not I mean some people have very
little sex but they don't fight and so
they get along some people have you know
have more sex but they you know so it's
really the ratio of the matters it's
called the positivity ratio the
psychologists study and and that's
really what determines how happy you are
how well something's going it's a good
way to measure progress and some of I'm
in a lot of the book it we're gonna get
into the larger kind of social and
political implications of a lot of the
work here but I mean a lot of it is
almost I don't want to say self-help but
it's it's news you can use both in your
relationships and at the job right we're
trying to tell people how that you
basically bit in relationships you know
first do no harm that it's the bad stuff
that really matters and that avoiding
bad is so much more important than doing
good like you don't get extra credit for
for going the extra mile for doing more
than you promised but you pay a really
big price when you don't but then it
seems in a way you can found yourselves
or contradict yourselves because you
talk about a high school football coach
who is famous for always trying on the
fourth down you know and and you guys
look at the numbers and you it turns out
statistically it actually makes sense
for football teams to go for it on
fourth down right almost always but
almost nobody does
why don't work coaches go on fourth and
you know fourth in a yard and well
that's one consequence of the negativity
effect we call it safety dicks and the
people get so obsessed with you know
what's the worst outcome because that
what's the bad outcome they fixate on
that and therefore they and they're very
irrational in their safety addiction
that I just don't want to risk that
I mean Lenore scan Daisy a reason has
written about how parents are obsessed
about letting their kids walk to school
because they're so obsessed with the
chance that a strange woman so if you
have one kid who is brutally kidnapped
and disappears forever you need to have
at least four more heads to make up for
not exactly that that's not in the book
explain the Garcia effect and how that
sits into
you know the the themes of your book you
know back during the glory days of
behaviorism when everyone was studying
how whereas responded to rewards and
punishments you know there was this idea
that you had to have instantaneous
reward or punishment for a rat for it to
happen and they were doing these
experiments with rats and they noticed
that they were subjecting them to
radiation and they noticed that you know
that some rats when they drank from this
sweet liquid and then later got
radiation and got really sick they would
never drink from that same you know
plastic thing was liquid again and yet
the pain you know from drinking from
that and had nothing to do with it but
they associated it with it but the weird
thing was is it it was supposed to
happen within like two seconds so you
know you had to do the the reward of
punishment and this happened months
later and people thought Garcia was
making this up there was something wrong
but they found that something bad that
that radiation that was so bad that
people actually could learn you know
that the learning could actually take
place much later which you can never do
that with good I mean a reward would
never work that way
unless you gave it immediately after it
but the penalty you know the pain was so
much stronger that actually work later
and as a result I mean or this this
comes into play when people if they
drink too much they blame whatever
liquor they happen to be blaming and
saying well when you get sick once on
one kind of liquor then people don't I
mean I don't drink gin because of one
you know time in college when that
happen and I think that's like one bad
thing can make so much difference these
won't touch it again let's talk about
where the negativity effect or the
negativity bias comes from you mentioned
you know part of this is evolution what
what does that mean and if it's
evolution you know can we really change
anything well it's definitely adaptive
because I mean the people who survived
on the ancestral savanna were people who
paid more attention to they were the
ones who [ __ ] more than they thought
they did that too yes and and so you
know but they they were very alert to
threats because you know what you know
one mistake can kill you and in that
sense it's still useful because one
mistake can still really hurt you at
work or it can still hurt you it can be
fatal too but the problem the analogy we
draw is that it was useful in the
ancient savanna to fatten up on calories
during lean times but it's not so useful
today when you surrounded by it
by junk food all the time and today
we're just surrounded by bad all the
time well one of the bad things that you
particularly point out it has to do with
social media you guys are critical of
social media although not in the way
that a lot of people are but talk about
how does social media kind of amplify or
screw with the negativity effect I mean
it's amplified in the sense that you get
this instantaneous reaction in the end
that people can use as a platform to go
negative and it's an easy way to get
instant attention but the interesting
thing about social media versus mass
media is that mass media appeals to our
common interest you got to go to math
and and the things that we all share
those interests or it tend to be
negative we're all afraid of dying we're
all afraid of crime we're all afraid
that's what mass media goes for but but
the things that the good things that
interest us you know our cultural
passions and Winterson the science or
into certain kind of art those things
are very are much more individualistic
and that's what social media is better
at and you know that and so people tend
to be more positive on social media than
mass media people tend to share positive
stories much more than negative stories
the mass media you know this is filled
with bad news but social media most
people now the people who really
dominate Twitter these sort of pundits
who are slugging it out they're trolls
they're negative but on social media
people who post more positive stuff on
Twitter they actually get more followers
and retweeted more often than negative
stuff because people don't share
pictures of school shootings they tend
to share stuff that they're passionate
about you know books that they like and
you know and people on social media are
looking at you know unfit on YouTube
they're looking at how-to videos at
Comic videos the stuff that they really
like as opposed to negative you know
scare stories and even in mass media you
point out you point to studies of kind
of counts of negative terms positive
terms and places like the New York Times
and the news is actually more positive
than it is negative right right there is
this thing called the Pollyanna
principle that a researchers started
counting the number of positive and
negative words that people use and and
and they've sort of expanded this to
massive data base things looking at all
media and the surprising thing
is that people use positive words more
often than negative words in every kind
of medium and even when you look at at
you know a tragic novels they're still
and you know I mean the endings are
pretty bad but most of it is fairly
positive and I and I think this evolved
it's our natural defense against
negativity that we basically tried it
over and that's the secret to overcoming
the negativity effect is basically is
overwhelming it with positivity and we
do have this natural tendency because
we're social animals I mean people don't
like being around people who are Downers
so you basically you know there's a such
a reward for being upbeat for using
positive words and I think we naturally
tend to do that you know even on Sundays
when there's a terrorist attack or
something you know Twitter immediately
goes negative but then it tends to
rebound because people start posting
stories about someone who saves
someone's life during this you know we
have this natural tendency it's you know
to want to deal with that somehow
but another factor on why negativity
wins or you know the power of that
overwhelms is capitalism itself really
you quote a line in the book saying no
food one problem much food many problems
how does you know you you are a fan of
capitalism you're a defender a proponent
of it how is capitalism implicated in
the power of that I mean one way is
simply that it's an easier way to get
people's attention when you're selling
something that's basically scary you
know you have bad breath you have this
problem and I'm gonna scare you about it
and get you to buy a product but the
larger way is it as you say that as you
solve basic problems like you know like
where's the next meal coming from
we had our brain as this natural
tendency to start looking for problems
and so we start finding new problems you
know there was a great experiment Dan
Gilbert did where he was asking people
to identify all the blue dots you saw
and they would reduce the prevalence of
the blue dots as time went on and people
would we keep seeing the same number of
them they started identifying purple
dots as blue you guys you caused a
prevalence induced concept change and
basically that the richer you get you
know the more first world problems you
find so let's talk about some of the
ways to combat the negativity effect
because your subtitle is how the
negativity effect rules us and how we
can rule in
some of the ways to combat the
negativity effect you talk about prizes
over penalties what do you mean by that
penalties worked better than prizes but
we tend you know there's been this whole
everybody gets a trophy movement and it
comes out of the self-esteem movement
and you know which is one of the sorrier
mistakes in psychology and in parents
and teachers I just want to point out I
would have no trophy so if not for
participation trophies screw you but
continue and you would be so much better
off today that's what's holding me back
exactly you also talked about combating
the negativity effect by delivering good
news last but not always but what what
is it about you know when you are you're
giving people good news and bad news
why does it make sense to deliver good
news second and was a classic example
this is the criticism sandwich which
managers used to give which is that you
start out with you know some good stuff
that you know then you Sam was in a
little criticism and you end with a
little good stuff but the problem is is
that once you hear criticism affects you
so strongly then when you hear that it
basically you forget what you heard
before that's what you know so someone
who gets and they can say you did all
these things right no but here's a
problem that's all they remember so
basically and most people would also
rather hear the bad news first most of
us would rather give good news first
because it's easier to start that way
but people want to get the bad stuff out
of the way and then after they get the
bad stuff their brains on high alert and
then the other good stuff can sink in
once the brain is on alert that way you
talk about there's a great chapter in
the book about a place called the
Casablanca hotel which is here in New
York City and it's the Casablanca hotel
versus the moonlight what how is this in
object lesson and how to overcome the
power of that the Casablanca has been
has been in the top ten usually the the
number one hotel in New York and
TripAdvisor for more than a decade and
they are just fanatics about about
overcoming the negativity effect because
what kills you is a few bad bad reviews
you know and and so they are just
fanatics from the moment you call that
hotel to make a reservation when you
arrived that the other guy who greets
you at the door
front desk they want to eliminate any
bad thing at all that could happen and
they've they have every single step of
the way and they mingle with the guests
every day at receptions it's all about
trying to avoid any bad thing at all and
avoid those negative reviews and the
moon lady would left a particularly bad
review this crazy woman can't you know I
showed up at midnight and wanted a room
with a view of the moon and they said
well and this is in the middle of
Manhattan surrounded by time by
skyscrapers and they gave her a room and
then she posted a review claiming there
were no windows at all in the room which
was just ridiculous and but that kind of
review can kill a hotel because it's
just you know a one-star review makes so
much more difference than a five-star
review and so that but they basically
hitman is in her and her review stayed
up but they have just swamped it with so
many positive reviews and and and that's
sort of the key to downline success is
avoiding the negative you mentioned in
passing the Pollyanna principle what
what is that and how does that work in
this context I mean that's the brains
and natural tendency to to fight back by
overwhelming bad with good stuff it and
and it specifically refers to the this
idea that we use language more often
good words more often than bad words and
we expand it to this whole idea of
Pollyanna which is this dreadful novel
and a movie about this you know girl who
plays the glad game and she's glad about
everything that happens and it's really
I mean it's awful you know people have
always hated this book cause it seems so
you tell the story of the first people
silent movie of it we're like gagging
the right where filmer was nauseated to
started her career and it's always been
this huge and that's like you know being
looking at the upside right it's
whatever happens you're glad that it
happens and and and there's bad at the
Sun I mean the reason that movies
succeeded so much is it it does Express
this fundamental truth and and that and
psychologists have found a bunch of glad
games for people to play yeah and then
that's the glad game is another way of
talking about this that includes things
like changing the narrative sharing good
news rejoicing in other people's good
news lists listing blessings and
gratitude having nostalgia but not
getting stuck in the past could you talk
a little bit of
you know we're often told if you have
nostalgia you're screwed because you're
always looking backwards and you're
stuck in the past why is why is a
certain amount of nostalgia a good thing
well that was the old view that it was
considered this pathology and there all
these bizarre explanations it was a sign
of depression and then in the last like
you know 10 or 20 years they've been
doing experiments and they found that
actually nostalgia really did it lifts
your spirits and it makes you more
optimistic it actually makes you feel
warmer when you're in a cold room and
people who engage in the styles are more
often tend to be happier that's one
reason that older people tend to be
happier than younger people is that they
engaged in more nostalgia and you're
basically just enjoying those you know
those memories from the past now the bad
kind of nostalgia is when you're
thinking oh those are the days we'll
never get them back yeah you know a
better way is they just think that was a
great time I'm enjoying that and sharing
it with someone else is great to you
both remember those moments you talk
critically about the crisis industry of
what you call the crisis industry and
you compare a woman named patty
Wetterling to the creators of Megan's
Law
can you explain who patty Wetterling is
and why she's a you know she's somebody
we should model ourselves on well I I'm
her son was killed one of these awful
stories of a child being abducted and
there was a law passed named after her
son and then and she was there in the
Rose Garden when they signed Megan's
laws he was one of the activists so and
this helped create national sex offender
writes the whole registry and so she was
of course all for that and then she
realized and then she started to see
inland or scanned a Z and the reason
I've written a lot about this you know
it said these laws have just turned out
to be awful things that are in snaring
all these people and ruining people's
live and she has now turned into a
crusader against it and one of the
proposals in the book the other we have
is called a lesson at Patty's Law which
would be a law forbidding any law from
being named after a child or anyone else
because it's one of the cheapest
emotional tricks is the name of law
after a victim because how do you vote
against a victim you also talk about
maintaining a low bad diet what does
that mean and can I have ice cream a low
bad diet is basically curating of the
I mean that it's a general concept for
your life is trying to avoid bad things
you do trying to avoid overreacting to
bad things and try and basically to get
a good positivity ratio and you can do
that especially in in the media you
consume by choosing whom you follow by
choosing what you watch and you know
trying to keep the ratio of bad stuff I
mean when there's a terrorist shooting
in our school shooting
you know don't wallow watching live
coverage here is a question for you when
you when you blow this stuff up from
kind of the personal world or your work
world to the political world
it's clear that politicians mostly trap
well they trafficking a lot of bad stuff
they say you know if we don't do this
crisis you know crisis will happen or
we're already in a crisis you guys
mentioned the vaping epidemic right now
et cetera why do people assume that
political solutions will work if we're
wired to being pessimistic or negative
about most actions that people take I
mean the Chicken Little
you know stories are great parable I
think where she over interprets this
crisis and acorn falls on her head she
says the sky is falling and then there's
this classic reaction something must be
done this is something therefore must be
done and what happens is is that the Fox
comes along and says you can all seek
shelter in my den and that's what
happens when there's a crisis that
there's this crisis industry of
journalists activists politicians who
declare a crisis and then they offer a
solution for it the benefits some
special interests like the Fox or or
benefits politicians and it grows the
government you know this is one of the
things in my career that when I first
started in the newspaper business as an
intern I found myself shamelessly hyping
this weather story you know and and and
I was thinking why am i doing that I'm
trying to turn this routine thing into a
crime what do you mean by that talk
about the way well it was a silly story
I was at the Philadelphia Bulletin and
Annie and there's a low man on the totem
pole
I was a sander I'd there's a heat wave
in August and I had to write about it
and so I was calling the police at the
Jersey Shore for like what's going on
everybody's fleeing to the shore and I
started asking you know the death
sergeant is this the worst traffic
you've ever seen and Muslims say it's
all
bad Nagas but one guy says yeah it's the
worst I've ever seen in my story the
next day is and what police called the
worst traffic in history and even then I
knew how sleazy this was but and I
started wondering you know why does this
happen why do we hate this stuff so much
and and then a lot of my career in
journalism has been observing that every
crisis that you see in the news you know
when you look into it
you know it's not as bad as it seems I
mean our rules are that the world will
always seem to be in crisis the crisis
is never as bad as it sounds and the
solution could easily make things worse
could you talk you know the biggest
story now and there aren't like nothing
but big gigantic stories you know kind
of rolling around that but is probably
global warming climate change very
quickly you know because the people who
talk about it say you know we have 10 or
12 years before it's all over baby why
are they wrong and why should we be
skeptical of the green New Deal or other
fixes right you know make the weather
perfect again right and well the same
people doing this to the people who
previously told us that we were going to
starve to death because of
overpopulation the billions were going
to starve to death and then they and
then there was the energy crisis where
we're all gonna run out of energy when
those things didn't pan out what happens
is there is this crisis industry and as
soon as one thing doesn't happen they
pivot to another now now I agree with
Rahm Bailey reason that climate change
is a real problem it's not a catastrophe
at the moment but with the long-term
saying there are problems but it's a
classic case where the you know turning
into a crisis doesn't work there have
been so many bad predictions and so many
attempts to blame every little bit of
weather for that a lot of people simply
don't take it seriously anymore and you
know so further and the other thing is
that the solutions that the crisis
mongers are pushing don't are completely
on unrealistic so you know they're
pushing you know solar power and wind
power and greens for instance in Germany
and in Europe they're against fracking
that they're against natural gas and
nuclear power which are the only two
practical methods at the moment of
making a large-scale difference I mean
the u.s. is actually doing much better
at reducing emissions
Europe is because we're not listening to
the green prescription and so what
happens is that they is they're seizing
this crisis this supposed crisis to
basically you know line their own
pockets and to create four more jobs for
themselves right and literally to
advance an agenda that has nothing to do
with climate right so exactly guaranteed
job program and things like that you
obviously you have decades of experience
as a as a journalist and you both I
guess
abetted certain kinds of scare mongering
as well as you spend I'm in you're best
known for kind of puncturing a lot of
you know scary mess Roy Baumeister
psychologist a lot of the book relies on
relatively new psychological research
how do we know I mean as a lave reader
how do you know how to sift through
what's good and what's kind of junk
science because there's you know
psychology psychologists are putting out
papers every day some of them are good
some of them are bad all of them kind of
get treated equally in the press right
it's very tough I mean one thing is is
that bad news of course always gets more
attention and in writing about this
about social media for instance I
started looking into and my inclination
was gee social medias bad for us we're
seeing all these things of Facebook
depression and Instagram Envy then I
started looking more and I found people
who done meta analyses and they said you
know really this stuff doesn't really
hold up you know that you know teenagers
some people are affected by social media
but really still the main thing the
teenagers were affected by is people in
their you know real life and and so
teenagers have always had this so I
think you know there's a you know
there's it's hard to sift out this stuff
I think you have to try and rely on and
not just one study not on one small
experiment involved in college students
but you have to look at it's someone
who's really surveys something that's
been replicated and I mean the
negativity effect I mean to toot my own
horn there have been hundreds of studies
on that now that Biggie and of basically
confirming it so so it's a full-blown
mass hysteria so we must believe exactly
if enough people do well leave it there
we've been talking with John Tierney he
is the author most recently of the power
of band how the negativity effect rules
us and how we can rule it John thanks
for joining
for reason I'm nickel sp
[Music]